The Fast family's tenth chapter is over – or is
it? After that stunner of an ending, it's clear
that there's more story to tell in the world of
the Fast and the Furious. Here's what the movie's
credits scene tells us about all the action
to come. Warning: spoilers ahead for "Fast X."
In case you ran out of the theater to take
off on some of your own street-racing action,
you should know there's a mid-credits
scene after the last shot of "Fast
X" – and it has massive implications
for the future of the franchise.
Dwayne Johnson being in the movie has
been spoiled for a little while now,
but the devil's in the details. When Dominic
Toretto and his team close the movie with a last,
explosive cliffhanger, this scene
sets the stage for what's next.
The mid-credits scene shows a giant, masked
man decked out in high-tech military gear
investigating an abandoned building.
Inside, the voice of Dante Reyes can
be heard taunting him. Dante makes threats to
the masked figure, promising nothing short of
a meeting with the devil to pay for his
sins against his father, Hernan Reyes.
Then we get the big reveal. While Dom may
have been the one who pulled off the heist
that killed Dante's father, he wasn't actually the
one to pull the trigger. That would be none other
than Dwayne Johnson's larger-than-life
character, special agent Luke Hobbs.
"Who the hell are you?"
"I'm what you call an ice cold can of whoop ass."
Right on cue, the masked man pulls down
his disguise and reveals the glorious,
goatee'd face of Luke Hobbs, returning
to the "Fast and Furious" universe for
the first time since 2019's "Hobbs and Shaw."
While his presence in the movie is
a pretty big throwback on its own,
Hobbs' vibe in "Fast X" also feels much more
reminiscent of his characterization in "Fast
Five." Even in this brief teaser, Johnson
is clearly leaning into the cartoonish,
gritty rage that Hobbs exuded in his first
appearance in the franchise. It's a bit of
a reversal from the Dwayne Johnson charm the
actor brought to the role in later movies like
"The Fate of the Furious" and "Hobbs and Shaw."
He even grunts out a perfect "sumbitch" to boot.
"Well hello, you sumbitch."
The scene is everything "Fast"
fans could have hoped for,
and it's especially shocking given
all the behind-the-scenes bluster
surrounding Vin Diesel and Dwayne
Johnson's professional relationship.
Johnson's return was revealed online almost
a week before the film's release. It likely
gave some fans flashbacks to a similar
incident last year, when the post-credits
scene for Johnson's "Black Adam" was also spoiled,
seemingly on purpose, a week before its release.
The news that Johnson was returning to the
Fast franchise came as a major surprise,
following a public feud and apparent fallout with
Vin Diesel. The actor had previously
stated clearly, on multiple occasions,
that he had no interest in returning to The
Fast Saga outside of future "Hobbs and Shaw"
sequels – even after a public appeal from
Diesel for his co-star to return for Fast X.
It's possible that Johnson's initial decision
was made when he was planning to devote the
next several years of his career to building a
universe around the DC Comics character Black
Adam – plans that seem to have been scuttled
after a change in leadership at DC Studios.
Perhaps the decision not to rejoin was more
professional than personal, and the cancellation
of future "Black Adam" sequels gave Johnson
space to re-commit to the "Fast" franchise.
In any case, Hobbs' return to the "Fast
and Furious" universe can really only
be a great thing, as the character
opens up more organic storytelling
opportunities for the upcoming sequels to
explore. Perhaps they could even finally
reveal the true identity of the Eteon
director introduced in "Hobbs and Shaw."
Regardless of how it shakes out in future
films, it's just exciting to see Johnson
returning to one of his most iconic roles.
We're going to have a hard time waiting
for his reunion with the rest of Toretto's
crew in the upcoming sequels to "Fast X."